Right nice it's really important me to see as much as possible. I would try this omelette here display with a
Carol deputy table the KE on this and I'm gonna go after that for the
Honey, pecan salmon, okay, and then good old-fashioned fish and chips. Oh, yeah. Thanks
excellent
You just have been staring at me nice, um big muscle head meatball
It's not my crab meat how do you want anybody to get the misconception not official
Here's
a pretty bold statement
Thank you my darling Wow the size of that that's a lot of crap and you haven't told me about decay yet
Oh, he said he wanted everybody to know that it wasn't real kravitz artificial crap
So he spelled it with a k' so there was no misconception. So it's fake crab meat in a seafood restaurant on the water
Holy crap brother takes this does go straight to the trash
Table didn't go over. Well, he doesn't like the crab in there. I-i've never that was already here. I didn't buy that stuff
I don't want to use frozen fish
it's not product that I'm absolutely
Overly proud of but at the same point I'm held accountable for all the inventory that the owners have paid for the food so far
Why we serving fake crab in our own way. I don't get it that you're the general manager
Why are you off I give the choice have you been drinking? No?
The crab was shocking embarrassing and fake. It tastes disgusting. Have you tasted that crap? No, I'm extremely allergic to
Crab shrimp, so I can't mean there's no crab in there. I
Understand it's my fish. Oh my gosh
I'll let you finish early
General manager my ass
And we live he things that actually allowed him to do that poor letting him serve those types of a ration
Let's take them AJ is the general manager. He's supposed to oversee the food
And now I'm hoping and praying that Gordon says AJ's the one that's bleeding this business, okay
Suddenly the best-looking thing I've seen
Some really rubbery is a frozen the fish I believe it's wrong, okay
When you take it by to that card, it's almost like you've got a breaded condom in your mouth
He said it was rubbery
Too greasy and just that it tasted like a frozen Cod and obviously hit it right on the buttons
This is the same recipe that we've used here forever. So I'm for change. I want to change good
wow, this one is the
semolina
dad
Thank you. Three. I
Think just so sweet
the
Dressing is like honey. That's so much of it
Absolutely disgusting quite possibly one of the worst salmon dishes I've ever eaten
It's a pretty successful opinion though tower of seafood a
big big club
What's in there? This is a layer of shrimp salad the later Vaughn crab cakes bacon and lettuce and tomato. Thank you
How to start easy sandwich this wire I mean honestly it's cautionary death I
Surrender to break it down
Deconstructed
Wow the crab delicious
It's a very pleasant surprise. Let me tell you
It's nice layer of crap and then he's stone-cold shrimp
Underneath
manda
Works this bit here. I mean then the text either week-old you might
Got their ghastly
To the fridge
Just have a word after this. It's all about sex. He almost takes by the
Tainted yeah
Just a mess. I'll leave that one done
So the shrimp tastes like that the head like a weird aftertaste her like I'm Lucy's play really the refrigerator
He's gonna taste like their old
a lot of the menu items are
Crap, it's Denise's recipes. It's the way she wants it done. I
Don't understand. This is perfect
Denise never think she's wrong. This is burger stand. That's her biggest downfall
It's good enough are we happy with this?
I'm taking a sleaze stick it Denise does what Denise wants to do and she won't listen to me. She won't listen to anyone else
It's aggravating
English-style fish and chips. Well English style for me macro House cut fries from fresh potatoes
And what kind of fish is it cod fish cod fish? Okay. Well
Simply use everything just greasy
No
Okay, great, thank you. Thank you
Sighs the nightosphere this trans fat to the batter soggy does even stick to the fish
Stressful mache when it's dry. Let's just drive. Well the whole batter just sort of almost like peels away from it
Those fries or shame?
Was just so soggy with my fingers. Yeah, we have 50 tips. And the tastiest thing on the plate is the tartar sauce
It's a big disappointment. I love fish and chips shame
The cooks are doing the best that they can with the way they've been told to do things
So it's nice this fall over all greasy fish fry the batter is just falling off of it
And I said the fries they were much changed really that's weird when he squeezed it and all this like grease all over him
French fries, you know
You get some potatoes that are one way and potatoes are another way and they're having a problem with a consistency of the potato
I mean, it's just making me crazy
First name is Catalina Catalina place me
You're the I'm one of the owners latch chest
Okay, I have a partner Marcelo is a man what we used to be married
We've been separated for two years. You used to be married to my partner. Oh Jesus. This is like water and oil
We just don't mix it's just like conflict all the time. Well, it's all about the food. I'll look through the menu
Nice to meet you. Oh
My god real interesting bit cool. Yeah, this is like a song
How are you sir? Yeah, how are you yeah rowdy. Thank you. Let's start off with
Chicken classic soup. Let's go for the pescado Mona or the Italia. Yeah. Absolutely. I really believe to check rice
You're gonna gonna like the food. I think that
97 percent of my food will be great
Thank you very much. And that's very fast. Very fast. Indeed. Let's hope it's good
That would be a pain in the ass because I the superficial it's co hot. It's cold. Let me get that for you. Okay, absolutely
He would like a hot soup not cold will say that Ramsay said
What happened with the school I
Have a thermometer here boiling hot. You wanna check?
To me it wasn't boiling up and now it's boiling hot this varies
But when we're know if it was before you guys send something out, please check double check triple check
Yes, yes listen go to the bar
I'm sorry about that. My just when I went to taste these
these are
Salty, I mean you'd need six mojitos before you start eating 6 spoons of that mate
They're disgusting. Excuse me. Let me take this back
shame
the basics I'll
Try that means
Oh
God there's definitely definitely a lack of harmony in the kitchen
1 DS 1 light light now
There's gonna be a complete disaster
How you doing yeah fine
Angie I'll find can I get you anything else while you wait? No, no, wait for the clap. Yeah. Okay. Thank you. All right
Thank you very much
Wow, I know I can't believe it it beats the basing of us I
Hope you enjoy cuz it's actually my favorite dish. Thank you
Delicious well, yeah
The fish is not cooked. Oh
It's really not that
Is a shame I'm gonna bring it back. That's a very big mistake on behalf of the kitchen
Okay possible not cooked
Raw fish wrong with you guys is wrong cook. I put the tester that the open
this is
This mannequins wrong, what's wrong
Excuse me Santa Catalina, please Chris. Hello, Canada pressure heat should not be on the kitchen at all
Listen and no playing around right now. I don't worry about we're gonna know this put your phone away
Are you all ready? Oh yes, let's start off with lobster bisque. Okay, sir, I'll get for the
Marinara, he's one of the house specialties wonderful another leech. The people akari's worth chicken and garlic sauce on the bone
Love it beginning I walked in I thought was a phenol now i'm is finally got me back. Okay. Brilliant
I hope who's doing everything? Yeah, I can't wait
What makes you got nothing to do with this order?
Iein, hang on my boys the drive
But I'm so confident overseeing my guys that I got nothing to worry about these guys been by my side 15 years
Now go go go go. Let's see what he thinks
They just looks disgusting
My queen is always a scream. Yes. You're a queen like
It just looks like loves was dead before they killed him. They're from a lot of fun to tank
You want to take a look? Okay?
See that
No, I think they're just sleeping
You must be dead. We keep a good eye on this. They keep a good eye on them surely not
Bass parts of dirt a dead Lobster now, he's gone. Okay
What I'm concerned about is everything else in there they've been feeding off that lobster yes and they become full of bacteria
Look, that is extremely
Unacceptable dangerous people could get extremely sick with that. I'll get rid of this right now. Okay, please
Love you. Bye
Don't smell that lobsters fresh even though it died it's good